one other quick thing Yahoo sports
UFC president Dana White admits to
slapping his wife on New Year's Eve now
this is a story that's gotten a lot of
attention uh Dana White slaps his wife
beat his wife as some on social media
have put it
lots of outrage about this lots of
claims that white is a domestic abuser
lots of condemnation Etc uh before we
talk about it let's check the video here
it is
[Music]
okay
so there it is
um so his wife slaps him he slaps her
back and all the headlines saying Dana
White slapped his wife could just as
well say Dana White's wife slaps Dana
White but we know why they don't here's
what I'll say about this you know the
position
most people especially on the left
have on this condemning Dana White and
this maybe this is a theme we're talking
about today people who have incoherent
positions well the position of most of
these people again particularly on the
left
it's an incoherent position
because if you truly believe that men
and women are entirely equal there is no
difference between the two in fact the
categories don't even exist according to
you they don't even say these words
don't even mean anything if that's what
you believe which every person on the
left just about pretends to believe
then
there just is no basis for condemning
for for any like serious condemnation of
Dana White because then you have one
individual who was slapped by another
individual and that individual slapped
back so yeah you could blame them and
say you'd be the bigger man uh you know
be more mature or whatever but
it it's to go beyond that just doesn't
make any sense
so if you're consistent in that belief
then you should look at that video and
react to it the exact same way that you
would react to a different video of a of
a man let's say a smaller man walks up
to Dana White slaps him in the face and
then Dana White slaps that man back
if you believe that men and women are
entirely equal
um then you should react to the one of
him and his wife the same way you'd
react to that and how would you react
how would anyone react to a video of a
smaller man walking up to Dana White
slapping him in the face getting slapped
back almost every single now there might
be a few people who say uh you know be
more mature
but almost every person would respond by
saying well don't go up and slap Dana
White I mean you got slapped back as you
slapped him if he's a bigger guy you
shouldn't be doing that
fafo right F around and find out that's
what everybody would be that's what
every single person would be saying and
we all know that
so to Heap
any sort of extra condemnation on Dana
White that the only way to do that
the only way to condemn him Beyond how
you would condemn him
if he slapped another man who slapped
him first which is you wouldn't condemn
him hardly at all in that case the only
way to do it is on the grounds of
chivalry
it's on the grounds of like a
recognition
that men and women are not equal
and that there are codes of chivalry and
conduct
that men should abide by
that men should men should treat women
differently from how they treat men
and women should treat men differently
from how they treat other women
that is the only basis upon which
you can coherently condemn Dana White
here
but most people doing the condemnation
they don't accept that basis and so it's
all it's all income here
which by the way you know and I'm a
Believer in chivalry
um
but does chivalry lead to the conclusion
that it's never acceptable under any
circumstance for a man to strike well no
of course not I mean there there could
certainly be and have been conceivable
scenarios where uh self-defense is
necessary like you're not you're not
called upon as a man to just be beaten
silly uh and to not defend yourself at
all because the person doing it as a
woman that's absurd
but generally as a kind of a general
principle
if you don't subscribe to the leftist
notion that the Sexes are equal then you
see that they're unequal and uh you
think well men should respond in
situations differently to women and then
they respond to men and I'll do it for
this portion of the show as you move
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]